we often hear that death is not the end
and that's especially true in movies
characters are shot blown up and
beheaded but death can be easily
reversed for a sequel
for proof just check out these glorious
returns from the unknown
but be warned spoilers lie ahead
ask a younger generation of movie buffs
about character resurrection
and a lot of them will think of eight
words
so tell me what's become of my [ __ ]
as captain hector barbosa jeffrey rush
doesn't just go from dead to living
but from evil to good as well in pirates
of the caribbean the curse of the black
pearl we learned that an aztec treasure
cursed him and his crew to walk the
earth
long past their deaths with their true
nature as undead corpses revealed by
moonlight
he's finally released from the curse
when missing coins are added to the
stolen treasure just in time for johnny
depp as captain jack sparrow to shoot
him dead
but in the pirates universe there's more
than one way to beat the reaper
after jack himself dies in the sequel
dead man's chest his crew goes to the
shack of the mysterious tia dalma to
hold awake
she reveals that she knows an
experienced guide who can sail them
through the seas beyond the grave and
barbosa walks down the stairs
sure enough he guides the crew to davy
jones locker in
at world's end and brings jack back with
him despite his early death barbosa ends
up becoming the only primary character
besides jack
to appear in every installment of the
series until he gets killed
all over again in dead men tell no tales
long before barbosa bit the dust one of
the biggest deaths in fandom was that of
spock in star trek
ii the wrath of khan and it was an event
that had plenty of longtime fans
thinking the exact same thing
are you out of your golf in mind in star
trek 2
khan activates the genesis device a
machine so powerful
it can reorganize an entire planet at
the subatomic level
spock sacrifices himself and dies of
radiation poisoning while repairing the
ship so it can get to safety
of course it was a heartbreaking moment
for everyone especially kirk
live long
and prosper spock then gets a full
funeral with his coffin launched into
space which seems about as
final a death as you could ask for not
so fast
in star trek 3 the search for spock we
learned that spock's body landed on the
new planet formed by the genesis device
his consciousness however has been
transferred to dr mccoy
so the enterprise crew has to save spock
from the collapsing planet and reunite
his mind
and body you won't be shocked to learn
that their mission was successful
bringing spock fully back to life by the
movie's end
alien 3 is one of the most divisive
movies in the series
but if there's one thing its detractors
and defenders agree on it's a cruel grim
piece of work the only disagreement is
whether that's good or bad
this mean streak carries to the end when
ripley burns herself alive to destroy
the alien gestating inside her before an
evil corporation can weaponize it
this ending feels like director david
fincher's attempt to make sure both
ripley
and the franchise were good and dead
forever
as we all know that didn't work five
years later ripley was back thanks to
cloning in the appropriately titled
alien resurrection
hey i thought you were dead yeah i get
that a lot
but she isn't quite the ripley we knew
her dna has been combined with the
creatures
and weaver's bug-eyed emotionless
performance feels truly alien
director jean-pierre jannu handles the
resurrection with the same dark humor
and surreal touches he'd shown off in
his earlier films such as the city of
lost children
a scene in which ripley discovers the
grotesquely mangled clones who preceded
her is particularly memorable
there's definitely a cynical meta joke
to ripley being brought back by greedy
creeps who refuse to let her die
just so they can squeeze more money out
of her but how you feel about that
probably depends on how you feel about
the movie as a whole
whatever you might think of these
explanations for characters return trips
from the great beyond at least they get
an explanation
not every character does take ezra
miller's character credence barebone
from the fantastic beasts series
in these harry potter prequels eddie
redmayne plays newt scamander
a major zoologist who arrives in new
york to discover it's being terrorized
by a ball of dark energy called an
obscurus which is caused by repression
of magical abilities
he eventually learns it's attached to
credence the adopted son of an
anti-magic crusader
newt confronts credence in the subway
tunnels and tries to peacefully talk him
down
but a bunch of american wizards barge in
wands blazing
they don't just kill credence they
obliterate him leaving nothing behind
but a cloud of debris
nevertheless british ministry of magic
officials informed newt in the crimes of
grindelwald that credence survived
and if you want to know how you're out
of luck it's all happening in a universe
with magic so naturally one can just
throw their hands up and accept that
it's magic as an explanation while many
questions linger it seems unlikely that
any answers will magically appear
one of the most iconic resurrections in
21st century cinema has to be gandalfs
as portrayed by ian mckellen in the lord
of the rings the two towers
gandalf doesn't just get a return he
gets an upgrade too
he comes back with all the powers that
had belonged to saruman
before he lost them by siding with
sauron
once he was ganned off the grey but now
he is gandalf the white
director peter jackson plays up the
drama to tremendous effect
gandalf's death scene in which he
bellows at the towering demonic balrog
is
unforgettable
jackson also carefully filmed gandalf's
return to catch new rings fans off guard
as legolas warns his companions that the
white wizard is approaching
certain that he means saruman they
prepare for battle and the audience is
misdirected right along with them
then a wizard appears with his face
hidden by blinding light
only to resolve into gandalf while many
fans love character resurrections
just as many think they're terrible for
a recent example consider emperor
palpatine's resurrection in star wars
the rise of skywalker in the original
trilogy palpatine first appears in the
empire strikes back as the shadowy
puppet master of the galactic empire
before appearing in the flesh in return
of the jedi
though he attempts to bring luke
skywalker over to the dark side he is
unsuccessful and gets thrown down a
shaft by darth vader for his trouble
that seemed like the end of it and it
was until the first rise of skywalker
trailer closed with luke's words
no one's ever really gone and the
emperor's familiar raspy laugh
as the release date approached fans
waited expectantly to see how he'd come
back in a series that had mostly avoided
reviving characters from the dead
in the end the only explanation we get
amounts to somehow palpatine survived
and has returned
many fans were unsurprisingly displeased
but his return to the living didn't
annoy fans as much as what he does when
he gets there
he reveals that he is rey's grandfather
a twist so bizarre many fans had
predicted it entirely as a joke
but in the end only some people found it
amusing
unlike most characters on our list this
one had to wait many years and many
movies before he made his dramatic
return
in captain america the first avenger the
red skull is a nazi officer whose
experiments gave him superhuman strength
but they also flayed the skin from his
face
he uses the mystical tesseract to power
his collection of space-age weapons
until cap knocks it out of its casing
and the red skull tries to hold it in
his bare hands which seemingly
disintegrates him
a year later in the avengers we learned
that the tesseract is
actually the space stone and that it
works by opening wormholes in space
comics savvy viewers immediately guessed
that the red skull hadn't been killed
just sent
elsewhere it took six years but those
guesses were confirmed in avengers
infinity war when the murderous thanos
arrives on the planet vormir
looking for the soul stone he's greeted
by a hooded figure who reveals a
familiar
red face the red skull explains that the
tesseract transported him there and
since he didn't love anything or anyone
enough to sacrifice to the stone
he guides others to a treasure he can
never possess
no genre loves bringing characters back
from the dead as much as slasher horror
does
this tradition goes all the way back to
1978's halloween
and its iconic villain michael myers the
classic flick leaves his death uncertain
with a final scene that reveals his
corpse has disappeared after being shot
multiple times
sure enough he's back to kill again in
halloween two and later sequels find
more and more outlandish ways to bring
him back none of them however
quite top his baffling return in
halloween resurrection
the previous movie halloween h2o 20
years later ends with laurie strode
straight up hacking meyer's head off
so hard it rolls across the ground how
do you come back from that
well according to resurrection that
beheaded body isn't michael at
all oh my god she killed the wrong
person
a flashback explains he switched clothes
with a paramedic before laurie caught up
with him
it works better than it has any right to
the fake michael grabs at his mask at
one point as if confused why he's
wearing it
but there are a lot of things this
doesn't explain for starters why would
the paramedic lunge at lorry
as soon as he wakes up in the van and
why through the whole thing but
especially when laurie's coming at him
with an
axe does he never think to just take the
mask off to reveal that he's actually a
middle-aged man with a mustache
in the original nightmare on elm street
freddy krueger returns from the grave to
torment the children of the people who
killed him
but the series is all about finding new
ways to make sure he stays dead for good
and none of them seem to work
in nightmare on elm street 3 dream
warriors neil gordon the psychiatrist
treating freddie's current round of
victims
learns he can put the killer away for
good by dousing his bones in holy water
it seems like our long cinematic
nightmare is over at least until
nightmare on elm street
for the dream master as the film starts
a character dreams that his dog is
taking a fiery leak
then a pit opens up revealing freddie's
remains
his bones start reconnecting his scarred
flesh reforms
even his signature hat is back and
that's all the explanation we get
well except for this you shouldn't have
buried me
i'm not dead freddy's creator wes craven
came up with a much more elegant
solution when he returned to the
franchise in new nightmare
freddy's still dead but he turns out to
be much more than just a fictional
character
he's an ancient evil force now free to
enter our reality he targets original
nightmare star heather langenkamp and
the rest of the cast and crew before
heather finally banishes him to the
world of fiction once again
serial killer charles lee ray first
cheats death in child's play by using a
voodoo ritual he learned from an old
accomplice
transferring his soul into a doll the
ending of this film practically dares
any sequel maker to find a way to bring
chucky back he ends up burned to a crisp
then he has an
arm a leg and his head shot off finally
he takes a bullet to the heart
yet bring him back they did child's play
too is the most
inexplicable return in the series it
opens with the play pals toy company
cleaning up chucky's severed head and
building a new doll around it
why would they do this according to a
playpal's executive it's to prove that
no one at the factory tampered with the
original voice cassettes which
could have convinced chucky's owner that
he was evil of course
none of this makes much sense all that
matters is that chucky is back
i always come back check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite
characters are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one